[Musik]
frau gönner
vielen dank für ihre hilfe gern ich
finde dass sammer erstaunliche
fortschritte macht sie ist intelligent
wir sind sehr stolz auf sie was ist
eigentlich mit ihnen mir ja sie haben
noch einen neuen job gefällt ihnen die
arbeit so naja
der unterschied zu meiner arbeit als
arzt sehr groß aber ich habe arbeit und
das am wichtigsten
wissen sie denn schon wann ihre
sprachprüfung ist die ist schon weitere
ja in ein paar wochen das datum aber
habe ich jetzt nicht im kopf ja das ist
ja auch nicht so wichtig sind sie denn
gut vorbereitet naja ich habe nur wenig
zeit zum lernen und ich kenne auch nicht
viele deutsche
ich spreche die sprache viel zu selten
ich kann wirklich nicht sagen ob ich es
schaffe aber ich hoffe es auch sie
sprechen doch schon sehr gut deutsch
herr papa ich möchte wissen ob es
möglich ist dass wir selber
sprachunterricht ab jetzt wieder bei mir
machen
es tut mir sehr leid aber das ist nicht
möglich
selber hat uns angelogen wir konnten ihr
nicht mehr vertrauen
ja ich meine nur gibt es nicht
irgendeine lösung hier geht es um
sammers zukunft das ist sagte familie
[Musik]